there's a cold absurdity to the fact
that you can play off you can play
extremely well and still lose
I mean the actually this year you've
played the what is it 50 days of World
Series of Poker and it seems like at
least from the perspective of me looking
at it through the internet it seems like
there's a lot of hands that you were
like 70 30 80 20 uh all in hands that
you just did not we're not going your
way that can sort of break you mentally
absolutely
yeah one of the hardest things
especially about playing because cash
games and tournaments are different one
of the most difficult things about you
know being a tournament player is
resilience because more often than not
like so if there's a tournament with a
thousand people to win the tournament
you have to get all of the chips that
means there's one winner and 999 losers
so it's very rare that you actually like
win all the chips so you're essentially
at some point in every tournament you
play gonna deal with like really bad
luck and disappointment and sometimes
those streaks can have you question
yourself and be introspective about okay
so I think I'm 47 now I think I've
gotten better as time went on between
distinguishing okay am I losing right
now because of bad luck
or is it fundamentally decisions I'm
making are not very good right and
that's one of the hardest things for
anyone who plays poker to get to right
why am I losing am I losing because of
my opponents being better I'm not
playing well or am I losing just because
of luck and because there's so much
variance in poker a lot of players can
be confused with on both sides of the
coin one guy's winning and he thinks
he's great he's really not wait till the
cards break even as we say you know I
think there's a lot of parallels to life
as well you don't if you get screwed
over over and over it's hard to know if
you're doing something wrong
or if it's just bad luck yeah I think
they did a study I remember there was
like a study it was supposed to be
related to gambling but it was mice and
they put them in a little maze and
they'd go down these three tubes and
they go down this one tube and there'd
be cheese right and then they go down
again cheese three times in a row there
was cheese there right the next time
there was an electric shock there not
cheese
the rat went you know the mouse went to
to get zapped he got zapped okay came
back he kept going back to get zapped
until he died like he kept going because
he found cheese there he has one there
so he continued to go chase that win
despite it being you know now all of a
sudden not worthwhile till uh till they
died and essentially what they said was
that is essentially how they uh compared
it to like you know the gambling brain
and how people think about gambling
you're chasing the winds you learn too
much you sort of over generalized the
lessons learned from the times you've
won so yeah like beginner's luck can be
detrimental if you if you have some
early luck and you believe that this is
just the way it's supposed to be forever
you know it can put you in a delusional
state where you know you you feel like
I'm just great but no you're not you
were just lucky in the beginning I
actually played poker once in Vegas it
was a
um it wasn't a tournament but it was a
kind of tournament-like style I already
forgot what it was but what I do
remember is I had four of a kind so the
last hand I've ever played
in poker was I got a four of a kind and
there was uh a couple of others with
really strong hands so everybody went
all in and I think you get some kind of
bonus for getting four of a kind bad
beat jackpot you were playing it yeah so
something like this I apologize if I
don't know the details but I just
remember winning a lot of money and I
walked away from the table I said I'm
not playing poker again this is great
because I started to feel like this is
your I started to think even though I
haven't really played poker at all that
I'm I'm good and I was a really
dangerous feeling and everybody was
really mad for walking away from the
table one of the other things is I think
it's interesting about poker 2 is good
as relative right yeah so you could be
the seventh best player in the whole
world like literally seven best player
but if you're playing with the other six
you're the sucker you are you are the
like the worst player in the game right
so like there's a lot of players
for example like the Dan bilzerians of
the world right he's not a top level
player like you know these guys you see
on TV but he probably makes more money
than they do because he plays with
people that are far below his skill
level so part of the part of the skill
of being a poker player is finding
situations where you're profitable you
know regardless of your skill level
another connection to life uh do you
think Dan balzarian is telling the truth
about having made what is it 50 100
million dollars just a huge amount of
money playing poker considering what I
know about the private games and the
types of players who play in these
private games and the stakes that they
play I absolutely believe you know Dan
has made I don't know how many millions
but I you know whether it's 50 whatever
but it wouldn't surprise me that if you
play in these games within a year or you
know you find the right businessman who
has way too much Bitcoin money you know
and you know in one night you take them
for 20 million I absolutely could see it
I don't see any reason why listen where
he got his money initially you know
that's up to interpretation from his
father or whatever but what but has he
made a bunch of money playing poker
absolutely no question do you feel like
as somebody who loves the game do you
think there's something almost ethically
wrong in playing people much worse than
you so yeah that's a good question
because
you know part of the reason I played
poker and wanted to become professional
was like I want to be make my mother
proud right and I don't think she would
be proud of me taking like Grandma
Betty's like last five dollars you know
and again down the street you know
setting her broke and taking her pension
check so why play at the high stakes
against people who can afford it they
know who I am I'm not a hustler I'm not
pretending I'm bad at poker to squeeze
in like I was thinking about this just
yesterday because I played in a game
that
if I played that sort of role where a
lot of guys do Pros they sort of play
down their skill level pretend they're
just one of the guys these guys can make
20 30 million dollars in a year
legitimately like I believe that like if
I did that if I said you know what I'm
gonna go down that path get into these
games in La you know and travel and do
all this kind of stuff I can make 20
million a year but it feels a little
greasy right I don't like to kiss
anyone's ass I don't like to ask it for
anyone for a favor or things like that
so but but yeah like
I I feel listen a rich guy who wants to
sit down with a million bucks and get
drunk and lose it I have no empathy for
that I'm like I don't have any moral
qualms with that so if uh Grandma Betty
is a billionaire uh okay give me send it
send it right you know absolutely why
not